-Our first guest
is an Emmy-nominated actor
and a very funny comedian
starring in the new film
"Home Team," which premieres
on Netflix tomorrow.
Here's the always entertaining
Kevin James,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
Kevin James!
Oh, I love you, buddy.
-Love you too, man.
-Welcome.
Welcome back to the show.
You look good, pal.
I don't know if I've ever --
Have I ever seen you
with a shaved head?
-Oh, yeah, I don't know.
This is the first time on there
with a shaved head.
I did a movie, which was, like,
a little sinister movie,
called "Becky," and it was
a different character,
so I shaved my head.
And then I was like,
"I'll, uh --
I'll just grow it back
afterwards."
And I started to grow it back,
and God stepped in and was like,
"Yeah, it's not gonna happen."
It didn't come in very thick.
So, I was like, "Ooh, maybe
I better stick with this."
You have good hair.
-Thank you.
Yeah, this is --
-Very good hair.
-Thank you. This is the best
toupee money can buy.
I mean, you can really --
-It really is.
-Yeah, the glue --
-It's tight on the side.
I like it.
-Yeah.
Well, it's a new year.
You got a new look.
I mean, are you doing
anything else differently
for the new year?
-I'm trying, as always,
to get in shape,
but it's just --
it's not working
'cause I'm older than you, man.
I'm just feeling --
I feel everything.
You know, the aches and pains
and just moving around.
I can't get motivated.
You know, it's even --
even getting out of bed
takes me, like --
I used to spring up.
But I don't know.
It takes me --
First of all, I have a mattress,
I've had it for like 10 years,
so it kind of knows me.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Got, like, the fat-guy divot
right in the middle.
You know what I'm talking about?
Like, if you walked
in my bedroom in the morning
and you --
You ever see half an avocado?
It would literally look like...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-The pit, yeah.
-I'm just
kind of stuck in there.
It takes me -- So that takes
a while to get going.
-Yeah, I sometimes --
I almost sometimes rock myself
to go like -- "hoo-ya"
and then get up.
-Yeah.
-And get out.
-A momentum thing to get out.
For me, even to get to the side,
because I sleep in the middle,
to get over, I got to get enough
weight over the side of the bed.
It's like -- You remember that
arcade game where the coins
where they just keep pushing it
closer to the side?
[ Laughter ]
Until you spill onto the floor
like a baby calf being born.
-How are the --
How are the kids?
You ever work out with the kids?
You do active stuff with them?
-I try to.
You know, I mean,
the shutdown, for us,
was miserable, you know?
And kids now --
You have how many kids?
-I have two girls.
-Three? Two.
-Yeah, two.
-They're probably active little
girls -- I don't know why.
I've got a boy --
just not active.
I try to get him going.
He's just --
Kids today, it feels like
they're less active
than we were.
I mean --
And I said, "Hey, we gotta
start working out, buddy."
And he's always --
it's always the video games.
And so I said, "Enough of that.
You can't do that anymore."
And he just tries to negotiate
his way out of it.
He's like,
"I don't want to do --
Can we please -- Can I --"
and I'm like,
"No, we gotta do
something active, me and you.
Let's go.
We're going."
And he's like,
"What if I got --" he said this.
"What if I got an Oculus?"
And I didn't know what
an Oculus was,
but it's one of those
virtual-reality masks.
-Yeah.
-And he was like,
"What if I get --"
because you can do things,
he says, on that
where you can be active.
He says, you can -- there are
boxing games on there
where you can box Apollo Creed
and Rocky or Muhammad Ali.
And there's sword games
where you're like a pirate
and all that stuff.
So, he's like, "I'll be active.
There's dance stuff."
And I said, "All right.
Well, maybe that would be
all right, I guess."
So, I let him get the Oculus.
And I swear to you, Jimmy,
there's a lot of things we do --
We talk about
and we embellish stories.
I wish I was making this up
about my kid.
Ready?
The first day he has it,
I walk down the steps.
I come down the steps,
I see him in the foyer.
He's standing with the mask
on -- the Oculus, right?
And he's literally just
standing there for 10 minutes,
just nothing.
And then, every once in a while,
I'll just see this.
I'll just see...
with his fingers.
And he did nothing.
And he goes like this, nothing.
10 minutes.
And I go,
"He doesn't look like
he's fighting
Apollo Creed at all."
[ Laughter ]
"This is not happening."
-No.
-I literally -- I rip it off.
I'm like,
"What are you watching?
What are you doing?"
I'm --
He downloaded a job simulator
virtual reality --
He got a job
at a convenience store,
and that's all he was doing.
[ Laughter ]
He was waiting for customers
to come in.
I'm not making it up, Jimmy.
I swear --
And he was ringing people up.
That's all he was --
He's getting, like, cigarettes,
and then he would
hand it to them.
And then he would sit there
and wait for the next customer.
He just sat there.
Literally...
[ Laughter ]
...nothing.
-Why didn't he pick
a different job?
-Pick up a mop at least!
[ Laughter ]
Stack some cases of beer!
-Mop up the fake --
-Yes!
He's sitting there.
He's a horrible business guy,
too.
He's scratching off
his own lotto tickets.
He's ruining everything.
[ Laughter ]
Very lazy kid.
-We gotta talk about
your new movie, "Home Team."
It's funny, as always.
Kevin James, is so, so funny.
But it's heartwarming.
It's something
the whole family can enjoy.
It's on Netflix.
Based on a true story.
Can you set up --
-Yes.
-Set up what the movie
is about for everyone.
-Yeah, Sean Payton, who is the
coach of the New Orleans Saints,
after winning the Super Bowl,
he got suspended.
It was that bounty gate
a long time ago.
And he got suspended for a year
where he couldn't be associated
with anybody in the NFL.
And I never knew this.
I heard about the suspension,
and I didn't know
what happened with it.
But he spent
that entire next year
coaching his 12-year-old son's
football team, the Warriors,
and he brought them
to a championship.
And he reconnected with his son,
and he brought them all the way
to the championship game.
And he lost the championship,
but it was an amazing --
He says it was the best year
of football in his life
because he connected
with his son.
And I disagree with him
because he won a Super Bowl.
It's pretty cool.
[ Laughter ]
Let's be honest, right?
The kid's great,
but that's second place.
[ Laughter ]
Right?
It's a Super Bowl, man.
-No, no, no.
The more important is that,
yeah, he connected.
-Yes.
-You guys got to see this.
It's great.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Kevin James
in "Home Team."
Take a look at this.
-He's at the 20!
He's at the 10!
Oh, my God!
Touchdown, Warriors!
[ Cheering ]
First touchdown of the season!
And just as the game
comes to an end.
-That was a touchdown!
It was a touchdown!
-Take it easy.
Act like you've been here.
-Yeah!
Booyah!
And, folks, that'll do it.
Final score here --
Warriors 6, Knights 38.
-We got a touchdown!
We got a touchdown!
[ Applause ]
-"We scored a touchdown!
We scored a --"
Kevin James, everybody.
"Home Team" premieres tomorrow.
Tomorrow on Netflix,
"Home Team."
More fun with Kevin
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.